as we continue our special series school
matters we are looking at the debates
over how to reopen schools safely amid
the pandemic
with many schools now back in full swing
or starting next week
a growing number of students are
learning from home in at least some
capacity
according to education week 39 of the 50
largest
school districts in the country have
chosen remote learning as their only
back to school model that affects more
than 6.1 million children
this morning as part of our ongoing
partnership with us
usa today we're sharing what all parents
need to know
to make remote learning successful usa
today national education reporter aaron
richards joins us erin good morning
and thanks for being with us good
morning glad to be here
you talk about the importance of parents
communicating directly
to schools and teachers about their
child's needs
during all this so how should parents go
about doing that
well this has always been important
right parents should always be
communicating with their teachers about
their child's needs but
now more than ever especially with so
many districts starting either remote
only
or with some online instruction and some
at-home instruction
it's really important for parents to
have that direct line of communication
with their teacher
via email via phone what is my child
expected to do
what are the grading expectations how
can i be a partner and make sure that
the at-home learning
is as successful as any in-person
learning that my child may be getting
also
one of the things that's really hard
about this is that remote learning
is not the same for every kid so
what should infect effective instruction
actually look like do you think
well it depends on what type of
instruction you're talking about when
we're
now that we've got much more of an
emphasis on providing remote and online
instruction for more kids
that should look like some live
interaction with your teacher every day
for kids who have devices and you have
internet that should mean that there's
some
number of hours each day that you're
online with a teacher and you're having
some live engagement with your peers for
that social connection
some kids don't have computers or don't
have a consistent
internet access so for those kids maybe
that daily check-in
is a phone call from your teacher or
maybe it's a phone call from another
staff member in the school
who can check in with that child and see
how they're doing every day
so which i mean you talk about there are
a lot of kids who don't have these
connections that you're talking about
there was a photo that went viral viral
recently of a couple of kids
outside of a taco bell using their wi-fi
because they didn't have it at home
there it is
so what do parents do if their kids
don't have this access how do they
ensure that
the kids are getting instruction
so you can ask your school district or
your school for individual paper packets
teachers can put together high quality
academic packets that guide children
through
a number of their academic concepts math
english science they can work through
those and these have been done
successfully in other countries where
kids live in remote locations
and those paper packets can be dropped
off weekly teachers can check in by
phone and so
families can still have that one-to-one
connection with their teacher
but a lot of times parents need to ask
the school for that material
if they don't have internet and if they
don't have a computer they can also ask
for those yeah
parents of course are many parents are
working from home too
they get distracted can't always look at
what their kids are doing
how do you ensure your kids stay focused
through all this
right so when i've talked to child
development psychology
and psychologists about this we've
talked about how important it is for
kids to have a routine every day
in the spring we saw lots of teenagers
develop some pretty wacky sleeping
habits
um you know a lot of them didn't have to
go to classes because
grades weren't being taken anyway so
this year
people are saying it's so important for
kids to make sure they get sleep every
night
that they get up in the morning maybe
they can't follow the exact same
schedule as they would if they were in
elementary school and you're
you know following a schedule for seven
hours in the day
but you need to be able to make sure
that you're meeting those classes that
you're getting online
that you're doing that academic work in
a part of the house that's conducive to
your learning
so some kind of routine is really kind
of essential is what you're saying
yes absolutely all right aaron richards
thank you very much
you can find more of aaron's takeaways
for parents on remote learning and
education uh in the covent era in usa
today